Europe's had a facelift and just in time
for Christmas that you use flashy new
headquarters called the Europa will be
used for future summits of the flocks
leaders it's a glass lantern shaped
structure it's also transparent like the
EU is supposed to be and is also
intended to make the institution more
inviting the myriad windows represent
diversity but because of the way things
turned out this year you could say they
represent the many crises the continent
went through there was the migration
crisis over which the EU is still
bickering and brexit forced Europe to
look at itself as never before and
populist parties are gaining more and
more voter support in many countries so
what do voters think of all this what
kind of view did they want and how
worried are they after University they
can't find something for them they must
go so to work you're like a waitress
same in restaurants and like a staff
small stuff and they can't find a good
job to leave even without refugees there
are too many of us in Europe it's tough
for them but it's also tough for us the
interior of the new headquarters is very
bright and colorful but does that really
reflect the mood of most Europeans most
of all I'm worried that the Turks will
someday become part of the EU from the
outside you're supposed to be able to
see the spacious main meeting room
inside and vice versa country leaders up
close or are these leaders actually
going to be in a gilded cage they should
be more present and let people know more
about what they do and how it actually
impacts their lives mmm
for example I can tell you exactly what
the EU Commission or the U Parliament
does exactly and how it directly impacts
me
the EU promises to be more approachable
however the problems it is facing are
much tougher than the task of creating
Christmas cheer with the new glass
facade of this troubled organization